إنها واحدة من الشكاوى الأكثر شيوعًا
من أولئك الذين يحاربون السرطان،
يمكن أن يستمر الإرهاق المزمن حتى بعد عقد من
خضوعهم
لعلاج السرطان، لذا فهي
مشكلة كبيرة جدًا، وهي اختصاصية تغذية
وباحثة مسجلة تانيا أوركارد في
مركز السرطان الشامل بجامعة ولاية أوهايو.  تقول أن هذا التعب يمكن أن يكون له
تأثير كبير على نوعية الحياة،
أولئك الذين يعانون من هذه المشكلة لديهم
مستويات أعلى من الالتهاب عندما ننظر إلى
دمهم ينطلق من نتائج
الأبحاث السابقة التي وجدت
فوائد التعب من الطعام Orchard LED، وهي
دراسة تجريبية ركزت على عدد صغير  من
الناجين من سرطان الغدد الليمفاوية، شعر الأغلبية
بتعب أقل بعد اعتماد
نظام غذائي شخصي، وإضافة
الأطعمة المضادة للالتهابات تدريجيًا والتي تشمل أحماض
أوميجا 3 الدهنية الموجودة في الأطعمة مثل
الأسماك، كما أننا ننظر أيضًا إلى الأطعمة التي
تحتوي على عناصر غذائية مثل الكاروتينات،
والليكوبين، وبيتا كاروت، وتلك الأنواع.
من بين الأشياء التي تحتوي على خصائص عالية جدًا من
مضادات الأكسدة والتي يمكن أيضًا أن
تقلل الالتهاب،
تقول أورشارد إن فيتامينات ب تساعد أيضًا تلك
الموجودة في الخضروات الورقية
والخضروات الأخرى، وتقول إن خمس
حصص من الخضار يوميًا هي
الهدف ويجب أن يكون طبقك ملونًا.
من الخضار الورقية الداكنة حصة
من الخضار الصفراء أو البرتقالية حصة
من الطماطم كل يوم ثم حصتين أو
أكثر من الخضار يوميًا
لدقيقة صحية أنا آندي غايثر